YACINE REZGUI:
Android Studio 3.3
is now available for download
on the Stable channel.
Along with version 3.3 are the
Android plugins for Gradle.
With this release, we
are delivering features
that we previewed this year,
including the Navigation
Editor, new tracking
option for the profiler,
improvement on the build system,
and lazy task configuration.
The Navigation Editor allows
you to create a destination,
define parameters, and specify
transition between them.
It's a big improvement
to be able to see
your whole application flow,
if you're using the Navigation
architecture.
You can link them
with drag-and-drop
and specify the
type of transition
for each user action.
The profiler now lets
you select the level
of data collection for live
memory allocation on devices
running API 26 or higher.
You can choose between
the full or simple mode.
This can improve
your app performance
while profiling, which
helps you to get closer
to a real-life user experience.
The CPU profiler lets you
see how long each frame takes
to render on the UI thread.
The profiler
highlights frame that
takes more than 16
milliseconds, letting you easily
identify when your UI
is not running smoothly.
If your application is
using obsolete APIs,
Android Studio now provides more
detailed debugging information
on which part of your
code is calling them.
You need to enable this option
by adding this line of code
to a Gradle file.
Build time reduction is
a continued focus for us.
We have improved incremental
Java compilation when
using annotation processors.
We also included a preview
of a new code shrinker, R8,
which is faster than ProGuard.
It doesn't even require
any code changes.
Give a try by adding this line
of code to your Gradle file.
If your project is configured
with multiple build variances,
the IDA will prompt you to
sync only the current build,
saving you time.
You can enable it manually
in the Experimental menu.
Android Gradle plugin now uses
a lazy task configuration API.
This avoids the cost of creating
unused tasks during Gradle
configuration phase.
Instant Apps are now fully
supported with app bundles.
You can create an instant
app and installed app
from the same project.
It makes it super
easy to split your app
and reduce its size for
a better user experience.
To deploy your app
as an instant app,
edit your Run configuration
and enable the option.
Enjoy Android Studio 3.3.
We are listening to your
feedback on our bug tracker.
You can test early
builds of the 3.4 version
on the Canary channel.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]